they had to invent a new word called Mal
information yes which is not
misinformation and malinformation which
is the information that is technically
true but it's inconvenient for the
government hey guys I'm off the grid for
August but the last sane Democrat and
I'm pretty sure I mean that literally
RFK Jr making sense as always there was
a there was a satire about President
Biden and his wife that they wanted
removed
oh you know these were like just
political decisions that you know they
weren't even and my information by the
way
I never posted any not a single a bit of
what you was misinformation
um the they had to invent a new word
what I was posting was actually correct
everything I posted on Instagram
was cited to a peer-reviewed publication
or to a uh or to a government database
so I was very careful
infrastructure probably more robust than
anybody else
oh they had to invent a new word called
Mal information yes which is not
misinformation and malinformation which
is the information that is technically
true but it's inconvenient for the
government yes so and that's what they
were censoring me for so um
so they were you know making that thread
we're gonna put your section 230
immunity unless you criticize unless you
shut down our political opponents
what if president Trump had done that
what what would we be doing if he had
done that okay
at what level would the decibels be of
our objections
if president Trump did that
oh but it's but it's there's no there's
no objection because it's being done by
in fact people say it's not even
happening
foreign